el gobierno de Joe biden y tres estados
del país lograron un acuerdo que titaron
de histórico la reducción de tres
jurisdicciones sobre el consumo de agua
del río Colorado hasta 2026 para su
conservación y así evitar el
desabastecimiento de las grandes
ciudades y los agricultores sin embargo
este pacto es transitorio hasta
conseguir una solución más efectiva
está claro que es un parche de Vital
importancia ya que nos enfrentamos a una
situación casi catastrófica no es más
que un parche para los próximos años que
nos dará tiempo a replantearnos la
gestión del Río
este convenio que estuvo tejiéndose
durante casi un año implica que los
estados de Arizona California y Nevada
cortarán 3.700 millones de metros
cúbicos de agua hasta finales de 2026 a
cambio de utilizar el 13% menos de agua
por tres años recibirán alrededor de
1.200 millones en compensaciones
federales
tres millones de Acres pie de agua
adicionales es bastante significativo
será suficiente sobre el tiempo lo dirá
Tendremos que ver si tenemos otro año de
escorrentía muy pobre el acuerdo mismo
reconoce que podría estar en esa zona de
peligro otra vez
el río Colorado ha padecido una dura
sequía en los últimos años con dos mil
trescientos treinta y cuatro kilómetros
de extensión provea 40 millones de
personas parte de México y dos docenas
de tribus nativo americanas además
produce energía hidroeléctrica y
abastece a las granjas que se encargan
de los cultivos invernales